the informal markets of Africa a
stereotypically seen as chaotic and
lackadaisical the downside of hearing
the word informal is this automatic
brand Association we have which is very
negative and it's had significant
consequences and economic losses easily
adding or subtracting 40 to 60% of the
profit margin for the informal markets
alone as part of a task of mapping the
informal trade ecosystem we done an
extensive literature review of all the
reports and research on cross-border
trade in East Africa going back 20 years
this was to prepare us for fieldwork to
understand what was the problem what was
holding back informal trade in the
informal sector what we discovered over
the last 20 years was nobody had
distinguished between illicit which is
like smuggling or contraband in the
informal sector from the legal but
unrecorded such as tomatoes oranges
fruit this criminalization what in
Swahili refers to as be Azshara
which is the trade or the commerce
versus Magento which is the smuggling of
contraband this criminalization of the
informal sector in English by not
distinguishing between these aspects
easily can cost each African economy
between 60 to 80 percent addition on the
annual GDP growth rate because we are
not recognizing the engine of what keeps
the economy is running the informal
sectors growing jobs at four times the
rate of the traditional formal economy
or modern economy as many call it it
offers employment and income generation
opportunities to the most unskilled in
conventional disciplines but can you
make a french fry machine out of an old
car so
this ladies and gentlemen is what so
desperately needs to be recognized as
long as the current assumptions hold
that this is crinum criminal this is
shadow this is illegal
there'll be no attempt at integrating
the informal economic ecosystem with the
formal or even the global one I'm going
to tell you a story of Teresa a trader
who overturned all our assumptions made
us question all the stereotypes that we
gone in on based on 20 years of
literature review Delicia sells clothes
under a tree in a town corn Manabe
on the border of Uganda and Kenya you
think it's very simple don't you we'll
go hang up new clothes from the branches
put out a tarp
settle down wait for customers and there
we have it she was everything we were
expecting according to the literature to
the research right down to she was a
single mom driven to trade supporting
her kids
so what overturned our assumptions what
surprised us first
Teresa paid the county government market
fees every single working day for the
privilege of setting up shop under her
tree she's been doing it for seven years
and she's been getting receipts
she keeps records we've seen not a
marginal underprivileged vulnerable
African woman trader by the side of the
road no we were seeing somebody who's
keeping sales records for years somebody
who had an entire ecosystem of retail
that comes in from Uganda to pick up
inventory someone who's got hand carts
bringing their goods in or the Mobile
Money agent who comes to collect cash at
the end of the evening can you guess how
much Theresa spends on average each
month on inventory stocks of new clothes
that she gets from Nairobi one thousand
five hundred US dollars that's around
twenty thousand US dollars invested in
trade goods and services every year this
is Teresa the invisible one the hidden
middle and she's only the first rung of
the small entrepreneurs the micro
businesses that can be found in these
market towns at least in the larger
mallamma border she's at the first rung
the people further up the value chain
are easily running three lines of
business investing two thousand five
hundred to three thousand US dollars
every month so the problem turned out
that it wasn't the criminalization you
can't really criminalize someone you're
charging receipts from it's the lack of
recognition of their skilled occupations
the bank systems and structures have no
means to recognize them as micro
businesses much less the fact that you
know her tree doesn't have forwarding
address so she's trapped in the middle
she's falling through the cracks of our
assumptions you know all those micro
loans to help African women traders
living alone her $50 or $100 what's she
gonna do with it she spends ten times
that amount every month just on
inventory we are not talking the
additional services or the support
ecosystem
these are the ones who fit neither the
policy stereotype of the low-skilled and
the marginalized no other white-collar
salaried office worker or civil servant
with the pension but the middle classes
are allegedly composed of instead what
we have here are the proto SMEs these
are the Fertile seeds of businesses and
enterprises that keep the engines
running they put food on your table even
here in this hotel the invisible ones
the butchers the bakers the candlestick
makers they make the machines can make
your french fries and they make your
beds these are the invisible business
women trading across borders all on the
side of the road and so they are
invisible to data gatherers and they
mashed together the diversity informal
sector that doesn't bother
distinguish between smugglers and tax
evaders and those running illegal
whatnot and the ladies who trade and who
put food on the table and send their
kids to university so that's really what
I'm asking here that's all that we need
to start by doing can we start by
recognizing the skills the occupations
we could transform the informal economy
by beginning with this recognition and
then designing the customized doorways
for them to enter or integrate with the
formal with the global with the entire
system thank you ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]